I would like the American political
process to change.
I don't know how or when or just don't
know how that would happen or how it's
going to happen.
I feel like we have this two party
system that is serving the two party
system and companies,
big companies in America and to the
detriment of,
of the,
the supposedly populous of America that
is supposedly the,
you know,
who the government is supposed to be
serving.
And I also think they environment is a,
is a big issue.
Um,
I was just reading about green
accounting this morning,
um,
which is basically trying to work,
the environment into the balance sheet
on a,
on a corporate level so that I'm
a so that if you,
you know,
the,
the example was if you chopped down a
redwood tree to make a picnic table,
like for the picnic table maker that
has,
uh,
you know,
it has an effect on their bottom line is
that has an effect on the US GDP.
But what effect does that have on people
who would normally use that redwood in
its natural sort of environment?
You know,
we have all this wealth that's,
that's essentially being created from
nature,
I mean from the energy of the sun,
from,
um,
both pretty much from the energy of the
sun and the energy,
the earth and through people sweat and
things like that.
And you have all these companies making
all this money,
you know,
from nature.
But I think the balance sheet is kind of
uneven in that regard.
We're not,
I don't think we're giving enough back
and at some point we're gonna find
ourselves in,
in trouble as far as not having enough
planet to live on.
Perhaps.